we begin this broadcast with the fierce
fighting raging in ukraine's eastern
industrial heartland there has been no
let up in the fighting in the donbass
region ukrainian forces are battling to
prevent russia taking full control of
the city of severe donetsk the regional
governor says constant shelling is
making it impossible to evacuate
hundreds of civilians
trapped in a chemical plant there
russian troops are also targeting
neighboring liciansk where the civilian
death toll is mounting
but the russian military offensive is
not just limited to the donbass region
ukraine has reported strikes on several
cities elsewhere in the country
a crater in the ground where a russian
missile strike hit
it's been 114 days since the invasion
began and civilians in pisarchin near
the north eastern city of harkeef still
have to live with shelling
significant damage was caused to
multi-story buildings private vehicles
and also factory workshops
moreover one administrative building
owned by piezogene village council was
damaged
workers at the factory that was damaged
don't know why they were targeted
we tested equipment for construction
companies
there was no military object in here
more than 500 kilometers to the south
residential buildings in mikolayev hit
by missiles local authorities say two
people were killed and 20 wounded
but besides attacks in the north east
and south the heaviest fighting is
currently happening in the eastern
dunbas region
in the embattled city of sierra donetsk
ukraine says hundreds of civilians
including dozens of children are
currently trapped in the azot chemical
plant which has been almost completely
destroyed
the regional governor of luhansk says
only a complete ceasefire would allow
them to be evacuated
the last city in this battleground
region that's still under ukrainian
control is neighboring liciansk but
shelling has also increased here in
recent days
yesterday at least four people were
killed in lizichansk in a russian
airstrike on a building that was
sheltering civilians the governor said
there was even more shelling today
leaving many dead
all right let's take you now to
correspondent imminently
she joins us from the ukrainian capital
kiev emma what more have you learned
about the situation in lissy chansk
well leila you've been talking about a
war of attrition and it's really what it
has come down to for the past few months
and weeks this heavy shelling that's
continuing uh from the russian side on
lizzy schansk on several doniers and in
lizards there has been
indiscriminate shelling a school has
been completely destroyed a residential
area has also been destroyed countless
people civilians uh dead in civil done
in a chemical plant the azad chemical
plant over 550 people have taken a
shelter they're waiting for evacuation
this is no longer possible the three
bridges leading to the city have been
destroyed and now also the motorway the
highway
leading in in and out of this city has
been rendered out of use due to constant
shelling today there there have also
been some advances from the ukrainian
forces in the areas of zapposia and
herzog
but it's really you know the war the
fighting intensifies in the west at a
time where russia
is you know re-uh reassembling its
troops also sending more equipment and
really focuses its offensive on the
donbass region so fighting intensifies
selling continues and civilians continue
to die
well as fighting intensifies in eastern
ukraine after yesterday's high-profile
visit of eu leaders to kiev i understand
ukraine's president zielanski had
another important visitor today
exactly uh
uk's boris johnson prime minister boris
johnson was here for the second time
since the start
of the russian war against ukraine
second time in kiev and he didn't come
empty-handed he said that
the united kingdom would intensify its
support to ukraine would also offer more
training
to up to 10 000 ukrainian
soldiers so another show of support
after after four
european leaders came here
in a kiev to show that western europe
was really that uh western allies were
really there for ukraine a gesture of
goodwill a gesture of support much
appreciated here in kiev and by
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski in
just a few words emma um of course it's
been a groundbreaking day for ukraine
kiev received eu candidate status what
was the reaction the general reaction
the general reaction is of course uh
also a lot of joy at this news you know
here in kiev a lot of people are
pro-european and also let's not forget
that this war is also
a war against european values against uh
democracy all uh all the things that
ukraine has been uh trying to
to tend to over the past few years
ukraine has you know undertaken so many
reforms and of course there are more to
come if it intends to join the european
union but
also feeling of relief that though all
those efforts have paid off with this
recommendation
by the eu commission for the candidacy
of ukraine
so lots of relief lots of joy tonight at
this announcement dw's emmanuel shaz
reporting from mckeeve ukraine thank you
so much emma
well in order to keep the hope of eu
membership alive ukraine must first fend
off ongoing russian invasion for this
task they desperately need weapons
ukraine has repeatedly asked germany to
supply heavy weaponry with mixed results
now a day after visiting kiev german
chancellor olaf schultz told germany's
dpa press agency weapons will arrive in
time to make a difference in the dom
pass region we understand that what is
needed now is artillery and this is
exactly what we will deliver at this
moment ukrainian soldiers
are
trained
in
germany for being able to use the very
modern howitzer we will deliver it
together with our dutch colleagues
and we also decided together with uk and
the united states that we will
deliver
multiple rocket launches which will be
very helpful for fighting from a
more on a distance aside of this we
are really helping with the necessary
things for instance fighting against
drones helicopters aircrafts with a
special tank we deliver for this the
training of the soldiers is going on in
germany at this time also
we will deliver
an anti-ballistic system which is able
to
save odessa or kiev
all right let's take you now to our
political correspondent thomas sparrow
for more details um that sounds like a
very long list of
deliveries that the german chancellor is
promising uh kiev when can kiev expect
to get all these arms
well you mentioned it in your
introduction uh the german chancellor
said that they would arrive in time to
make a difference in the donbas and
obviously now the question is what that
exactly means what does in time mean
it's important also to understand a bit
of context here because germany and in
particular the german chancellor have
been under a lot of pressure recently
about those promised weapons that
nevertheless have not been delivered
there seems to be a discrepancy between
those promises and the delivery of heavy
weapons and that's one of the criticisms
that has been particularly leveled
against the german chancellor and the
german government in recent weeks when
it comes to weapons in ukraine and as
such the german chancellor then stressed
that they would arrive in time i imagine
that statement by mr schultz in that
interview will raise even more questions
as to when those weapons can be
delivered some of them he clearly stated
depend on whether and when those
ukrainian soldiers are trained here in
germany the delivery will happen only
afterwards but that is not the case with
every weapon here involved so as of now
we know very little concrete measures
about when those weapons will actually
arrive in ukraine all right so short on
a time frame
in a related uh uh on a related topic
the chancellor was asked about why he
continues to talk to president putin
let's take a listen to what he answered
to that question it is absolutely
necessary to speak to putin and i will
continue to do so as the french
president will also
and there
are some
countries needed and some leaders needed
that speak to him and it is necessary
that they are clear
because
when i speak to putin i say please
understand that there will be no dictate
peace and if you really believe that you
will rob some land
and then hope that the times will change
and all the things be will become normal
again this is a mistake
the chelsea there thomas says he doesn't
mince his words when he speaks to
president putin does this policy of
direct engagement with president putin
enjoy widespread backing here in germany
there is one element to all of this
which is the military component we
already discussed that but the other
element is a possible political
negotiation and as such this is also a
policy that here in germany has been
pursued
with varying degrees of support since
the war in ukraine began we heard olaf
schultz the chancellor there stressed
that he continues and will continue to
talk to vladimir putin as other european
leaders have done as well and he
stressed the importance of what he
described as a fair peace in other words
a peace that cannot be dictated by
russia but must be accepted by ukraine
by the government but also by the people
in ukraine so it's important when we
look at the war in ukraine and the
reaction coming from germany and from
the eu by the way to understand those
different components that politicians
are following the military component on
the one hand but obviously also the
political component and the possibility
of a political solution which is
something that by the way i expect was
also part of the discussions when
schultz and his european colleagues went
to kiev in the last few days i imagine
that it was not only about restating
that european path for ukraine it was
also about discussing the possibility of
a political negotiation with russia
dw political correspondent thomas
sparrow reporting for you thanks so much
thomas want to tell you about some other
developments related to the war in
ukraine russia has reduced its natural
gas exports to europe for a third
consecutive day flows to italy and
slovakia have been cut by half and
deliveries to france have seized
completely
european leaders have called the move
political while russia is blaming the
cuts on a technical problem
russian president vladimir putin says
his country is not to blame for rising
global food prices
speaking at the international economic
forum in saint petersburg president
putin instead accused the united states
of driving up prices the president also
slammed the sanctions imposed by the u.s
and europe as reckless and insane